modern women how can we tell our price
well basically the price is what men
have paid before so if you're a chick
and you've been giving it out left and
right well joke's on you because you're
essentially like five dollars what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard videos before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in and
if you want to purchase a women
shouldn't vote shirt please get one the
link is in the description those help
support the channel so today we have a
very important lesson for you guys so
is he simping now this is a very complex
question and we can't we can't just
answer it simply all right I know you
guys want me to simplify it but we we
can't do that so what I've seen from
interviewing hundreds of men and
hundreds of women is there's really
three categories of men now I'd like to
say that looks and money do play into
this but it's not necessarily about
looks and money alone there's The Pimps
these simps and the sex list so there's
really three types of men in society
there's these are the guys that are now
I've been trying to swear less so effing
all right thing sorry guys but you know
they're doing the deed with most of the
women because again all of the women
want these guys right and in historical
times these would be the Kings and they
would have a bunch of concubines they'd
have all these concubine virgins in
their like layer or whatever but now
we've transitioned right usually the
chicks would be a concubine for a life
but now these guys are taking the chicks
making her a concubine for the night and
passing her on to these fellas now these
fellas tend to be the husband I hate to
break it to you guys but a lot of a lot
of your ladies were with these guys and
then went to these guys now these are
the sexless men they're not even getting
in the door
um I mean these are these are the obese
the ugly like they're not really
relevant because they're not no offense
guys they're just not a part of the
dating market so they're kind of out so
how do you how do you know which
category you're in Men In This category
women approach them men in this category
waiting for sex has never really been an
issue men in this category have to work
for it they typically you know they meet
their wife in their friend group
um befriend her for a year and then
later it becomes something
um they typically do things the right
way you know that that's these guys so
now how do you tell the difference
between these two categories again it's
not necessarily about money it's not
necessarily about looks but it's how how
they view women right so
um so over here does he say things like
happy wife happy life um does his wife
kind of run the household do they say
things like women deserve the world you
know they kind of put women on a
pedestal you need to do all this stuff
to qualify for the women
um instead of yourself pimps put
themselves first now it's not to say
that Pimps Don't ever become husbands
but The Pimps will never simp so how do
we know if the guy is simping or not
let's I'm gonna have to erase this
all right is he simping so what is a
simp now I'm gonna use this analogy with
cars I know us women we are not cars I
know for a fact but it's just easier
with this analogy so we have a Honda
Civic now mind you I'm partial to the
Honda Civic okay I'm very PR I had I had
a Honda Civic and a Lambo okay now a
Honda Civic let's just say a used Honda
Civic I guys I don't know car prices but
this is just just for the analogy stay
with me let's say you pay five grand for
the Honda Civic and you pay 50 grand for
the lambo now the difference The Pimps
and the simp is the simps will pay this
much money for this quality of the
product now a pimp very May well still
get the same car right but he sure as
hell is not going to overpay for it but
the problem is the problem is women
women have spent the last 50 years
convincing men that they are this now we
are this when really we're we're this
you know it's a nice car but you know
definitely not new and not the same
quality as the lambo now what men will
do The Pimps will do is they're very
cautious they know they realize women's
true nature which is to lie and just
make things up yada yada so they're like
okay let's we're gonna do things to
lower the risk because there has to be a
reward of women and a risk so
lower risk includes so things that we're
going to do up here is going to be
things that make her lower risk so this
is going to be like two parents uh no
tattoos uh no baby daddies or kids zero
kids
um no College I would say is a Plus
nowadays
um you know things like that now there's
things that make her higher risk which
is a tattoo sleeve
um uh kids a body count hi I'll put a
virgin up here too for the low risk sex
work now we're gonna go into the reward
category so this is the things men get
out of a relationship so you know uh
benefit would be maybe she's a good cook
maybe she's
um I don't know you know cleans whatever
serves her man oh actually on a risk I'm
gonna put no IG it's a plus for guy
reward could be multiple kids for him
not coming into the thing but multiple
children like you know like a benefit is
if she gives you five kids over one I
mean if the guy wants kids like it
depends what the guy wants maybe he
wants um assistant work and this guys
the reward all depends on the guy like
there's guys that get um what it's like
quote unquote executive wives and these
are wives that help them with their
business
um you know there's different guys that
want home-cooked meals every day like it
all we gotta whatever and obviously the
hotter to the the hotter the chick is
the more she can have you know these and
the less she has to have these right
because the hotness is the number one
you know you're not gonna get in the
door if you're not a hottie right
um now then we have the negative things
the chick does so this is like Behavior
so this is like annoying
um
partying
um guy friends
masculine
argues okay you guys you guys get the
point so every guy is kinda every All
The Pimps are weighing the reward the
risk and then also looking at the
annoying things we do and the bad things
that maybe we did in the past and
deciding now basically basically the men
go to the wife store and what they'll do
is they'll they'll say okay she's got
two parents you know no kids but she has
a tattoo sleeve and then they'll give
you a quote and same thing really just
becomes overpaying now how do you know
if you're overpaying really the men
don't so you know us they used to
basically men used to marry us in three
months because you know we were all back
then we were raised to be wives we had a
lot of this and we had none of this but
now the more the reward goes down and
the risk goes up you see me and walking
away from Marriage walking away from
relationships and really what The Pimps
Don't want so a pimp will come in The
Pimps know the most right they they've
been with all the chicks they've been
with hundreds of women so they just they
know the most they'll come in and say I
am not paying 50 grand for a five
thousand dollar Honda Civic and if I'm
gonna buy this Honda Civic I want to
make sure I'm getting the most reward so
these guys will say okay sorry
sorry guys lady you have to basically do
whatever I say for three years you maybe
even have to give me a kid first and
then I'll marry and it's not simping
because off the bat he made the girl do
a lot more
um before he bought versus a simp who
would come in and after three months
marry the chick even though typically
the Modern Woman today doesn't really
bring much of these things yeah so now
how can you tell how can modern women
how can we tell our price well basically
the price is what men have paid before
so if you're a chick and you've been
giving it out left and right well joke's
on you because you're essentially like
five dollars now those chicks could
still be bought right either by a simp
or buy a pimp who makes them do a lot
first in order to get bought but as the
data has shown us most of us at least
half of us will not be bought and
certainly not by the pimp but by the Sim
um so this is my analysis of the dating
Market guys um let me know what you
think I could be wrong you know this is
just pearls Pearl's opinion like the
video on your way out guys subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
and I'll talk to you next time